[Musique]
non
bonjour à tous bienvenue à rembobine à
la salle émission du moment qui vous
emmène en boîte de nuit et en compagnie
de thierry ardisson bonjour thierry bah
oui les boîtes sont fermés les boîtes
sont fermés moi j'ai commencé dans des
boîtes de nuit
d'abord dit choqué à l'âge de 16 ans au
whisky à gogo et jean les pins donc j'ai
une vieille ville carrière dans une
boîte de nuit après j'ai fait des
émissions dans des boîtes de voilà bain
de minuit et lunettes noires pour nuits
blanches sont vos deux premiers tokyo
sur la cinq puis sur antenne 2 ces deux
émissions qu'on a choisi de de découvrir
et de redécouvrir et d'explorer et on
n'a pas été déçu en fouillant les
archives parce qu'on ya trouvé des les
plus grandes stars de la musique du
cinéma de la peinture des politiques
aussi venus s'encanailler en boîte de
nuit donc aux bains douches ou au palace
donc l'idée l'envi du night club comme
décor c'est vous c'est à dire qu'en fait
main toute première émission sur tf1
c'était scoop à la une qui était tourné
au palais omnisports de bercy autre
chose donc je souffraient le martyre et
quand j'avais fini de tourner mon
émission j'allais boire déco bains
douches et un jour principe de plaisir
je me suis dit mais pourquoi tu fais pas
directement les missions bains douches
après tout non vraiment je me suis fait
plaisir a donc ça c'était important
et puis je voulais amener tous ces gens
là dans des boîtes nul et l'esthétique
qui flirte avec le pop art plus encore
dans dans l'une est ça aussi c'est votre
envie oui c'est à dire que moi en fait
je venais de la pub
j'ai fait de la pub pendant 20 ans et
j'avais été formé en fait aux graphismes
à l'image à la typographie
donc quand je suis arrivé à la télé
effectivement bah oui j'avais si j'avais
ça en plus quoi parce que les gens
n'étaient pas du tout avait pas cette
culture là disons non là c'est sûr se
mettre dans l'ambiance avec les
génériques des deux émissions qui sont
des bijoux de montage et de graphisme
avec iggy pop
mais d'abord avec verdi la traviata
non
oui
là
[Musique]
oh
mais là
oui
on va appliquer
[Musique]
et toi
oui moi
m
bah
mais
ou pas
m
wade
les génériques très classieux de ces
émissions qui n'ont duré que trois en
une saison pour bain de minuit deux pour
moi absolue net mais qui ont marqué par
leur style et leur casting alors ça on
va le voir tout au long de ce rambo
minable comment faisiez-vous pour avoir
autant de vedettes
d'abord j'ai eu la très bonne idée de
treilles catherine barma il est vraiment
infernal c'est à dire comme définissions
ensemble pour pour tf1 dimanche après
midi présenté par patrick poivre d'arvor
et un jour j'arrive premier jour
j'arrive aux buttes-chaumont jeudi à
catherine oué oué nathalie baye l'invité
ou et catherine abena talibans ils
voulaient pas venir
catherine est allé la chercher chez elle
voilà donc catherine barma c'est
quelqu'un qui était capable de prendre
un taxi des chercheurs invités qui
voulait punir
donc voila mais c'était une époque aussi
il faut dire les choses où les gens
données très facilement la télévision
maintenant ça a changé c'est à dire que
maintenant c'est un peu comme aux états
unis les gens et font pas toutes les
émissions tout le temps à l'époque on
disait que ça il était aux médias alors
il ya les faire venir et ensuite les
faire accepter vos mises en scène voir
vos délires ou vos jeux de rôle
on va voir parce qu'elles se sont
volontiers prêtés
à vos jeux le fameux blindtest
évidemment le dos interview dans ce
premier florilège on nous avons
rassemblé mick jagger et keith richards
steve your way je peut vous arrêter là
très bon en fait ça c'est une mission
spéciale
c'est une époque bénie où je croise
marie france brière dans les couloirs de
antenne 2 elle me dit qu'est ce que tu
fais la semaine prochaine loin tu veux
pas l'interviewer mick jagger et keith
richards
c'était et donc je suis allé à berlin
qui à l'époque était encore occupée
berlin est donc qu'ils étaient encore
occupés on a visité berlin ensemble que
on a fait de cette interview coupée en
deux c'était l'époque de grande liberté
donc jagger et richardson d'heure boy
george
cindy lauper yoko ono elia kazan karl
lagarfeld topor et enfin béatrice dalle
et serge gainsbourg
remember the time et qui switch
en fait ses portes il est il à emilie la
traite
j'écris tout se sait pas
mais elle est rapide sucre le riz comme
travail timide
wingles et bastos
m
saussez
brown
par les chants des 100 degrés we do with
you every night work with his final game
tchat
[Musique]
jon leyne peu plus j'y travaille peu
avec lui mais il est ce parce que y
je crois que il lui ne veut pas vraiment
partagé parce que après une après
quelques temps de faire les concessions
avec 200 c 'est de 30 ans serait
préférable de rester seul tous les ans
fin juillet soit tué
[Musique]
je reste c'est vrai c'est du riz at il
certifié
wen flash just marseille ne m'aurait vis
ma vie de ce barrage pourrait céder le
club c'est toujours un peu difficile
pour les gens qui fait les choses comme
ça parce que ça puisse aller claque va
disparaître malheureusement ce que je
prends moi j'ai mis le clash c'est le
land cool c'est très bon disent oui mais
ils ont raison parce que c'est un peu un
peu triste et ce moment tout le journal
et il faut toujours le gros qui laisse
un peu commun des indiennes qui mangent
avec humour et le dr ils ont toujours
besoin de les jeunes gens sont au
maquereau en bouche
alors toujours la jeunesse stupide
[__] bio pritchard lennon mccartney
[Musique]
malheureusement vous n'avez pas plus la
lampe pour par celeno 10 mai par les
télés très jeune et est les deux
ensemble ils sont pleins de talent ou du
like to be sais pas trop
f
cordes yoko ono nul 1-1 contre harrison
[Musique]
on est inquiet pour deux shows et
notamment des galeries dette
obama by ap abu d'uranium est une espèce
de petit pot d'accueil ou orienter mes
services chose on y est le christ à nu
metal and your wedding à l'artisanat
plus inégal a eu chaud aux et notre
terreau à pink and school à manhattan
ibérique ans est américaine
cette couleur à manidem anicet de
[Musique]
casting aussi couture est un pionnier
marie pitau aït baha donataire myspace
de démarrer
syncup chérie c'est peut-être dû au mic
thank you happy town rose n'a de
consonnes pour l'habitat tout cas de
l'athlète et piqué mais c'est tout bête
yoris france pour la dernière merveille
propos maire de tulle et chaumeil de
ahoua don mello nord libournais fait et
cause
[Musique]
c'est que développe story et une jaune
et rose combine une photo à adana 6 3 6
2 elle est créée pour gucci vingtaine
d'habitants weir a pris feu mark chapman
ici des cinq sens aurait voulu que tu en
voilà qu'en basse et nos coeurs
[Musique]
16h50 encore dit catherine peine
capitale et cause pour elle
un homme a thing tête on line up pour
domingo pénitence casting
steve yzerman
[Musique]
m
natixis
[Musique]
sexy tu termines de l'aed ce postiche
et là où nous sommes
aller grâce au stand by
ivana subasic m
[Musique]
ce choix
musique
[Musique]
pour y caser tous portent à la fois que
tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle va me manquer
il faut faire des cures connaître notre
âme
leur fils à 7,6 magiline sur la coke
toniolatti non loin du lac comme jacques
tati à mon nom
porto rico au continent de vidéos
nightwing ya six semaines et rémy
[Musique]
moi
ah ouais un traité ce jour il va aussi
amèrement 2
au masters
après deux petites heures hier
[Musique]
jimmie johnson
les troubles au bassinet stranger in the
mind et diomède while he is boys the
innocents soient jugés dans l'année soit
six compétiteurs et m
[Musique]
ouaga pour benoît
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lebel
[Musique]
mais sa famille est originaire de
hambourg
le monte à tout ce qui doit moins qu'ils
ont traversées comment ta famille la
deuxième guerre mondiale
je dois dire que j'ai eu de la chance
car kim aux états unis en 1938 quand je
m'en souviens très bien de la guerre
c'est comme s'il n'avait pas eu lieu
parce que mon père avait eu la bonne
idée pour une autoroute avec différents
d'acheter une propriété la frontière
danoise
juste avant la guerre et que j'ai passé
mon enfance et premier donné m'a mis du
temps à être prêté à la frontière
danoise où s'est rien passé ont des
parents étaient très riches tout en
question wii party c'est quand même
propriétaire entre le dreff les
commerçants du réseau visa l'argent
n'est pas tout et vous avez le bonheur
comme on dit ça peut aider mais je pense
que de faire confiance à ses enfants
confie ce risque on a envie de faire
même si ça correspond vraiment aux pas
aux idées de tes parents c'est le plus
grand de ce monde l'aura 14 ans qui est
venu à paris pour pour faire des études
habiter à l'hôtel d'ailleurs non vie
d'un truc pour étudiants au titre vous
était très bien je trouve ça génial que
c'est incroyable quelquefois je regarde
deux enfants étaient 14 15 ans et je me
dis
j'ai fait des maps ovi de tout seul
comme un dieu ta carrière tu as été
assistant d'avoir chez balmain
c'est très bien a ensuite été directeur
artistique chez patou une styliste chez
chloé dernièrement bien sûr sauveur de
chanel tout le monde le sait sauf leur
sauveur sauveur de il faut pas non plus
le sanglier
oui mais enfin je veux dire ça a été
aussi sauvé si tout a été arrangé
lorsque de propria de chanel a mis les
idées à ce qu'il fallait
parce qu on ne sauve pas uniquement
après dans la liste en disant voilà on a
pris ce styliste et maintenant ça va
marcher tout seul alors ça n'a pas
empêché évidemment de connaître une une
réussite exceptionnelle tu es riche et
célèbre
alors on va commencer par la richesse tu
as combien de maisons aujourd'hui
d'appartement je sais pas moi comme je
suis un décorateur frustrés ils savent
pas combien tu dessines de modèles je
vais bien croire mais les maisons tout
devient de se voir l'analyse la turquie
dans ce chantier qui dynamita
appartement à paris
il faut bien que le biais des moments
récents d'habiter à nous tel serait pas
d'électricité que tout était là je
croyais la pause une pièce là bas pour
une pièce ou une pièce à rome tu as d'un
grand atelier d'un quartier où il y
avait beaucoup d'ateliers de peintre
danois au 19e siècle et a appartenu à la
été l'atelier de doivent à un moment
donné à new york un petit lecteur
le message avait jamais je n'ai pas
beaucoup de bien à hambourg quelque
chose embauché maison sublime qui
l'avait d'ailleurs j'ai donné à la ville
d'avesnes ma vie elle est la vie parce
que c'est un monument historique très
très très bizarre qui n'est pas fait
pour ta grandchamp son manoir
l'angleterre vous écouter
mais j'y vais jamais l'année dernière
j'étais je crois 48 heures mais pour moi
c'est le pas nécessaire d'habiter que de
nombreux l'essentiel cela existe à ma
tête me dis que je peux en faire et
c'est un chantier l'habitable g j'ai
tout l'arraché à l'intérieur et pas
encore eu le temps de refaire dans ce
presque inhabitables je peux même pas y
toucher
enfin qu'à une pièce avec ses 25 mètres
de long qui remplit de vivre c'est vrai
c'est bizarre
aller du barrage à une parade à monaco
tu as quoi alors tu as beaucoup dérangé
par hasard plusieurs sources de cette
fameuse villa qui resterait qui est in a
occupé pendant les visites et la vigie
que tu connais d'ailleurs
et puis j'ai aussi un appartement que
quand je vais avec moins de monde que je
vais tout seul à côté du palais qui est
dû dans une maison ancienne refaite cia
qui fait 700 m² au 21ème étage
je n'ai changé il est moins grand sud
arrêt il a plus de charme parce que
jamais mieux puisque le syndicat bsa
mètres carrés sur une tournée qu'amusant
il fait même fiche mais c'était dans une
maison nouvelle évidemment jamais
habiter la maison près de la maison sert
qu'à mars c'est ça c'est ça de près
comme à la maison de retraite avec
l'ascenseur pour la même clairsemé mais
il faut bien trop lourd pour j'ai perdu
15 kilos peut être devrait on peut pas
monter ensemble au mois ou la voiture
mais pas les deux tu as dit aucune des
sociétés pour lesquelles je travaille ne
m'appartient c'est ça ton système
actuellement c'est le visage de royalty
exactement par des pourcentages vous
connaissez le flat fille mais je ne veux
jamais être concerné par tout ce qui est
gestion à faire je veux garder un
sentiment de liberté totale et que tout
ce que je fais je le fais parce que je
veux bien mais parce que tu es obligé de
le faire et pour moi c'est très
important
alors tu arrives tu célèbres c'est à
dire que y'a des gens enfin il ya des
sondages qui ont été faits quand on le
voit avec ton catogan en éventail et tes
lunettes mais pas les battre non mais on
dit on sait pas très bien ce qu'il fait
mais on sait que c'est karl lagerfeld et
ça c'est une bonne chose
oui oui c'est très bien qu'ils
arrivaient à apposer une image
médiatique où il très fort alors par
contre est au mieux avec les monaco a
fait très ami de la famille de monaco
ils sont mus élevé c'est vrai que tu
corresponds journellement avec le prince
rainier quand on souffre aussi de
pouvoir déjeuner d'affaires par contre
quand on lis dans la presse que tu
trouves le prince albert très spirituel
c'est vrai qu'a donné il est très drôle
ah bon donc ça tu confirmes pas fonction
très amusant il a une grande donc
d'imitateur et acteur qui est assez
méconnu mais je trouve très très
distrayant quand tu sais que tu es le
client idéal parce qu'on a inventé dans
cette émission qui s'appelle lentilles
portrait chinois
[Musique]
je serai une maladie un cancer dans un
bon cancer généralisé vrai mais encore
que le pari est les régions penser
qu'elle est une façon de faire la
sécurité sociale à la carte
on parie sur le kangoo varie si on gagne
on est remboursé le triple la
topographie ça peut rapporter gros
le cancer on ne sait jamais il ya une
maladie cardiovasculaire ou le penser
voilà les branchés incident ait à une
forme du corps est donc non mais y en a
d'autres actions voiture étant une
troisième
donc tu partirais tu t'es irait en
fonction de ce que tu as dix idées plus
ou moins cher et les autres seraient
remboursés moi je fais un truc qui est à
mon sens d'un cancer et si tu étais un
microbe
c'est un petit microbes mikron toutes
les microbes un champignon une truffe
invite si tu étais un vis à vis la
masturbation strictement que ça te plaît
c'est ce que tu préférais c'est ce qui
reste quand tout le monde s'en va
cet été une guerre une guerre non un
mouvement un mouvement
un moment guerrier ou en soutenant la
révolte du ghetto de varsovie je trouve
assez exaltant vient ouais le seul truc
en fin de chaque fois que les civils
casse la gueule aux militaires et
varsovie ton père oui oui mais c'est la
vie ça n'a rien à voir si simplement que
j'aime pas trop les militaires
l'accident un accident ouais pas une
essence très bonne réponse une cicatrice
non je dirais pas et d'albert vous
voulez la voir alors qu'avant elles sont
là toutes façons de faire mes fesses
tout enfin les chapeaux téléphone et si
tu étais un terroriste pour finir en
beauté un terroriste enfin vous ne suis
pas un terroriste
pas du tout non je ne vois pas comment
sur la merde quand même non la bon je
vous la merde tout la mer dans la dans
le fumier la bière fraîche non non je
m'accroche et 1100 de son fait l'été qui
vient en tête avec lequel le
questionnaire un pédéraste notoire
d'appel ce projet
première question par celle de son
prénom boost de son groupe
quel est pour toi le comble misère
de passer inaperçu moi j'aurais dit
absence de papier cul oui c'est moi qui
fais le test 1 2 seconde question le
projet aimerais-tu vivre las vegas parce
que parce que j'y ai passé une semaine
génial et que je me dis comme partout je
me suis fait chier je médite à la saga
ça serait bien tu peux officier à vegas
et jouer à flamber pas beaucoup vu que
j'avais pas trop de thunes mais c'était
marrant dieu quoi batista pas de thune à
tulle heures parce que c'est ce que je
dis c'est pas grave j'ai pas perdu
beaucoup de couches minces à l'accord
dont l'idéal de bonheur pur page
je dois pour nous voir puisque je m'en
mets en partout mais avec du fric en
face ou même par être obligés de
travailler n'importe quoi tu as dû te
match amical bah oui mais ceux avec qui
je me maquille sans jamais trembler
alors ça va
il est beau gosse il sait pas forcément
plein de trous quels sont les héros de
romans que tu pourrais faire c'est
difficile jamais rien eu vraiment une
bonne chose alors si vous mettrez way
presque jamais pas des romans des 000
points de vue vers l'infini tant
patrouille un numéro de francis bacon la
qualité préféré chez l'homme
e
qui joue sa gueule qu'on est nombreux
parce que son émoi que soit mon
téléphone et j'ai affable
je sais pas j'aime pas trop les femmes
largement foule en qualité et une femme
et qualité qu'est ce que tu as en toi je
suis gentille
je vis la porte à un moment j'ai pas
entendu les yeux vis la magie tels que
des yeux mais c'est autant les
occupations préférées plus facile parce
que ça j'en ai pas d occupation trophée
disent que tu as eue durant toute la
journée je m'emmerde souvent temps mais
je sais pas moi j'ai la sauce poignet
ben non non non ça va ça qui aurait tué
m je n'étais pas béatrice dalle c'est
pas que je suis contente d'être moi même
personne d'autre non plus
principal défaut
plus tôt
je suis jalouse c'est pas être pas de
foudre si c'est un défaut parce que ça
me prend la tête à moi bassi aussi mais
c'est à la limite c'est moins grave mais
ça me prend la tête à moins rapide que
youtube un défaut
ça me rend triste quel serait ton plus
grand malheur
[Musique]
e
être obligé d'avoir un travail tous les
jours
[Musique]
x passe ou à la couleur que tu préfères
e
vers bébé j'aime bien vers bby et
valentin ont foulé j'aurais dit kaka
doigt parce que ça sonne mieux le don de
la nature que tu aimerais avoir
je suis très bien comme ça alors
finalement ça va quoi jouer de la
musique ou à dire ça dans la nature en
savoie abrasif et ben moi c'est faire
caca sao de passer une classe comment
aimerais tu mourir je mens pas mourir ça
va la tête
je ne sais pas je me suis pas posé la
question j'ai pas du tout aucun plaisir
à mourir
moi j'aimerais mourir vivant the last
one quelle est l'étape et un ton esprit
les enjeux présents sous chrono présent
je sais pas ça va gainsbourg et béatrice
dalle gainsbourg qu'on va retrouver un
peu plus tard parce qu'il a beaucoup
compté pour vous et pour vos émissions
donc extrait de bain de minuit et de
lunettes noires pour nuit blanche avec
des stars décontracté dans une grande
liberté de ton ce qu'on imagine
difficilement aujourd'hui je crois que
même si on les met dans une ambiance de
boîte de nuit l'ancien ange je pense que
la boîte de nuit faisait pour beaucoup
c'est à dire oui c'est à dire que parce
que qui dit boîte de nuit dit champagne
qui dit champagne 10 cigarettes et c'est
donc moi j'ai toujours eu à coeur même
quand je faisais des émissions même tout
moment par à ce que ça soit vraiment
pour eux une soirée quoi série viennent
chez ardisson
c'est comme s'ils étaient invités après
je les fais être le dîner 93 faubourg
saint-honoré sur paris première
c'est cette idée quand même qu'il faut
que ça soit sympa que ce soit
décontracté éviter le jour est-ce que
parfois il fallait quand même négocier
avec les stars elles mêmes ou avec leur
agent qui vous disaient ça on n'en parle
pas oui les agents étaient moins
importants que maintenant tire
maintenant il ya un entourage hautement
insupportable je me souviens ma dernière
année
sur ces mythes il a fallu discuter trois
semaines pour avoir franck dubosc et
quand il était arrivé son attaché de
presse m'a dit tu lui parles pas de
gilet jaune
moi j'en avais parlé et du mois c'est la
dernière fois que tu auras franck dubosc
oui on en est à l'époque il y avait une
camaraderie avec les vedettes qui moi
comme je passais ma vie aux bains
douches
c'est dans mon élément alors au milieu
de tout ça une séquence qu'on a eu envie
d'isoler quand même une sorte de
dinguerie une facétie que vous allez
nous expliquer ces d'une interview du
grand cinéaste ridley scott vous avez
fait traduire de façon très très
particulière et l'italienne des renards
les djeunes vous choisissez dans votre
dernier film un thème beaucoup plus
réaliste pourquoi la réponse ça prend du
temps
je crois que metteur en scène vous voyez
il cherche toujours de nouveaux sujets
moi je voulais bouleverser un peu mon
rythme quoi jouer je passe je me tourne
toujours vers le passé vers l'avenir
alors j'ai recherché des thèmes
contemporains je voulais une histoire
d'aujourd'hui et sur des personnages
d'aujourd'hui dans des situations
d'aujourd'hui
et cette histoire elle m'a plu parce
qu'elle ne faisait pas servi même peu
comment dire à des années 40 se répète
un film de john garfield avec grace
kelly ou deborah kara c'est ma
contribution au film sur la vie
d'aujourd'hui quoi mince encore un peu
dans le passé voilà maintenant j'avais
commencé qu'est ce qui vous a pris de
face cote voix de deux chauffeurs de
taxi marseillais arrêt parce que je sais
faire déjà c'est pas vous si ses fils et
moi mais non monsieur faire l'accent de
pieds-noirs et l'accent du midi non je
m'en sert abondamment là bas on a écouté
ça plusieurs fois on se dit bien ce soir
j'avais commencé avec boy george et
j'avais fait exactement la même chose
qu'au montage avait refait la bud
georges avère en parlant comme ça et je
vous soumets à toute ma vie catherine
barma
moi je connaissais rien à la télé c'est
pour ça que je me suis ça
catherine gay comme la fille de claude
barma qui avaient été levées là dedans
m'appelle le jour de la diff a le sort
de la leaf le samedi soir à l'eau ouais
ben écoute ta carrière est terminée quoi
c'est fini mais pourquoi mais tu te
rends pas compte de ce que tu as fait on
avait l'impression vraiment que c'était
pour faire marrer les copains
ouais je sais pour décoller non ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que moi en fait
j'étais bon influencé par le rtf dans
mon adolescence
ensuite il ya eu 68 il ya eu les hippies
voilà après il ya eu la drogue après il
ya eu le palace donc l'époque palace
badouche quand j'ai commencé à faire la
télé jamais rien à [__] ça pour moi
c'était vraiment pas importante vers la
télé j'avais publié mon premier livre
seuil à 22 ans la littérature c'est
important mais la télé je m'en foutais
complètement donc je n'étais pas du tout
j'avais pas le respect que je dirais que
plus tard j'ai acquis du respect pour
tous ces gens là et heureusement mère
parce qu'un acquis sont respectables
mais au début je m'en foutais vraiment
jeté un puck chez une espèce de punk
alors on revient pour à quelqu'un pour
qui vous avez beaucoup de respect
gargiulo on l'a vu tout à l'heure est
aux prises avec béatrice dalle vous lui
aviez confié une émission spéciale il en
était le rédacteur en chef ça commençait
rester à gaza c'est son attaché de
presse philippe lerichomme m'appelle et
me dit est plus que coproducteur et me
dit cherry serge de faire une émission
avec toi ça n'arrive jamais il a mangé
obligé d'appeler quand même mais bon je
dis oui il veut faire ça l'après midi
bon d'accord on fait cette émission qui
lui lunettes noires spéciale gainsbourg
où il y avait béatrice dalle où j'ai
présenté antoine blondin parce que
choses absolument incroyable gainsbourg
n'avait jamais rencontré blondin alors
qu'ils passaient leurs nuits dans les
bistrots de saint germain tous les deux
il est incroyable et donc je vois là
c'était c'était assez c'était une assez
bonne émission on fait l'émission elle a
sorti jeudi à philippe reniche angie
mais pourquoi est ce qu'il a voulu faire
cette émission d'hier entre à l'hôpital
demain il voulait faire sa dernière
émission avec toi ce qui pour moi est
que les trucs les plus fantastiques une
fois arrivées évidemment et il est allé
à l'hôpital
il a survécu grâce à dieu je veux dire
c'était quand même il voulait faire une
espèce de testament télévisuelle et ses
lunettes noires et après bien des années
après j'ai fait l'émission que ça te
laisse r si tu nous regardes qui était
une espèce d'hommage évidemment vibre en
prime time
sur france 2 etc donc c'est gainsbourg -
je l' ai connus quand j'avais un petit
journal branchés aux halles j'allais le
premier nouvelle série d'interviews on
allait voir ce qu'ils disaient toujours
oui nos jeunes oui il est très
disponible
diablement est ce possible donc j'étais
allé le voir pour ce journal qui
s'appelait façade et une avait dit oui
on avait interviewé et après quand j'ai
fait descendre de police pour rock et
folk
le premier c'était sergent donc il y
avait une espèce de complicité de
complicité même moi je suis pas star
fucker j'ai pas passer ma vie à boire
des coups a dîné avec des stars au
contraire se raconter une anecdote vous
la coupe réglée quand la première de
bain de minuit
l'irie julien clerc qui étaient là et à
la fin de l'émission tous très content
et je viens coeur me dit coup devient
dit dans la maison la semaine prochaine
et je me suis dit si je commence à dîner
avec eux je pourrai plus jamais les
interviews mais parce qu on est copains
d'ailleurs les mecs avec qui je suis
devenu copain de l'ira talent darmon
chabat je suis un foutu les interviews
et parce que je les connais trop donc
j'ai pris mes distances dès la première
émission et j'ai dîné riche d'un
actuaire trente ans plus tard un soir on
se raconte et d'ailleurs je faisais très
attention et gainsbourg je n'ai pas
fréquenté mais entre nous il y avait
quelque chose quoi alors c'est qu'enfin
tout est bien mais dans l'émission
gainsbourg séquence évidemment
troublante il se laisse interviewé star
by starck barre sa dernière compagne
bambou séquence qui s'apparente un autre
face à face qu'on va voir ensuite et qui
a marqué l'émission
les retrouvailles d'anna karina et de
jean luc godard
quand est venue en pleine forme et
higuain donc c'est peu mais ce ne sera
pas une graine de voyous
6 tu ressembles ça serait bien fait rare
au caire
[Musique]
il fera ce qu'il voudra peut-être pas
inquiet
si la vie bras qui liera bras qui était
tirée à maîtriser
ok ça change quoi toi mec
trente deux ans de plus que toi juge mon
coeur
eh bien je pense que ça permet des
rapports privilégiés et inviolable
ce serait pas intello sur les bords
t'as ton contact je sais pas je le
disais je vais vous pouvez me serrer la
main je l'aï sacré quoi d'avoir un
enfant avec l'arrière nièce du général
von paulus
que je réussirai
si jen était l'héroïne de melody nelson
est ce que moi je suis samantha lil
wayne de hyundai sa mort les yeux gris
de me wade devait alors se jeter tête
baissée
[Musique]
lorsque je faisais ça bouge clauses
dites vous connaissez le parfum soleil
vert tient et française ça c'est de
namco
mais je suis un piqueur jeune escroc
mais oui tout ça manque quelque part
qui croit qu'on va rester longtemps sans
encore tous les deux mathématiquement
parlant je sais mais people sport
deux ans que
viendra un jour dans ce sens là
c est cruel c'est mathématique a tiré
huit mois supplémentaires
mongi roth tu crois que tu seras avec
tessi ne souhaite pas rencontrer
je pense que surpris
doit régner
m
en proto
on a coeur à coeur ça suffit une pièce
le reste antoine sort actuel dernier de
la dernière de nuit
ma p'tite cocotte minute pourquoi es tu
toi tu ferais quoi
suivant la région s'étaient pas
rencontrés je sais pas du tout je sais
pas si sûr encore lave et à plein de
choses que je n'aurais eu un destin vos
vêtements différents j'essaie de marquer
au fer rouge là et là indélébile
qu'est-ce qui t'énerve le plus chez moi
un des sautes d'humeur de
l'électrocardiogramme tu peux parler de
toi c'est pire que moi
je t'ai déjà cassaigne
tu te rappelles que le son disque nas
mais moi je suis un lâche j'ai rappelé
que moi je prends un couteau
ah ouais jeu du couteau précédent loua
les chiens toi tu ferais quoi cgt qui tu
es
[Musique]
bien sûr
10 29 c'est une quitter bab
je dis une chose mais cocotte du serait
pas la première
[Musique]
tu souhaites tu as ta dernière
cette affiche est content chaîne s'est
tiré avec traille ne commette l'accord
touche pas à ce que ta table à dire mais
les bears
c'est vrai qu'au début des années 60 tu
t'es marié avec une princesse quality le
garçon
peu partagé en deux
ben oui gaffe avec qui tu as eu de merde
avec les questions du style pas rester
plus ou le guen pas parce que je l ai pu
te bats la barbe est ce que tu t'es
marié sait que c'est que c'est que je
vous convie à partir du moment où tu
t'es marié que ça commence à décoller
c'est pour ça que tous les deux on est à
l'école
moi non plus c'est pas mal plus quand
même surtout les deux jeunes et selon
lesquelles que les faces qui quatrième
30 ans sam événements alors qu'ils en 20
ans c'est tentant de vous retrouver dans
une longue sieste puis des séries nokia
sabre laser
ils feront tout pour voir mais
personnellement oui mais
j'apprécie apprise aussi parce que je
m'y attendais pas les dames serena dans
une émission qui a bellemare a oui vous
êtes pu parler au téléphone depuis écrit
moi je suis passé lui relater ouais ça
va me trouvait trop dur dans la page est
tournée
vachadze elle est tournée mais le
bouquin et là ça vous a manqué qui vous
appelle pas
on peut tout dire à cette heure là c'est
un peu surprise après bon et qu'est ce
qu'on dit quand on se voit comme ça tu
en parles quoi le danemark
je pense pas ou n'ont jamais likoud à
noir mais deux fois manque le danemark
on se dit quoi mais vous savez une fois
qu'ils avaient quittée tu t'es ma mère
c'était c'était jean lui pour marie
c'était aussi un peu mon père mon frère
et puisque ceux des mines a prescrit ni
détournement de mineure non non pas du
temps je dirais pas été consentante
tournage pour nom tournoi mineur vous ai
fait combien de films alors le jeune
mineur ouais j'ai fait cette fille mais
denis c'est lui parce qu'il ya un sketch
à oui ça compte pour une moitié sera
fait et nous on a fait cette fille
nommée fais ça tu penses est filmé ce
que j'ai fait cette finale est un sketch
c'est fini
alors jean louis - kst lt comment comme
actrice anna à formidable formidable la
difficulté pense pour la salle en tant
que crime que critique aux journalistes
comme vous c'est que les peut-être sa
difficulté comme tant d'autres je crois
n'a particulier le cinéma n'était déjà
plus
ce qu'il devrait être pour que des gens
comme ça puisse trahie elle aurait dû
cry et hollywood merlhiot n est plus ce
qu il était donc et l'europe n'a pas là
cette puissance comme ça c'est une
actrice du si on considère ce qui pour
moi d'inventer loge enfin c'est une
actrice du muet c'est à dire qui c'est
qui peut parler sans qu'on comprenne et
on comprend tout ce label ce qu'avait ce
qu'avait de l'ue est une actrice musical
aussi donc dans la série des grands
paradoxes de madame déclare
effectivement que les gens étaient déçus
quand le parlant est arrivé que quand
comment avait lancé sont parlants
personne ne voulait y aller maintenant
vers les beaucoup lumière a fait le
grand café étaient tous en concurrence
edison aussi edison a présenté un jour à
paris l'un cinéma par modèle de cinéma
parlant et ça n'a pas pris
je crois que d'être tous les gens
étaient contents de pouvoir écouter
entendre quelque chose
ça l'est tout ce que je veux dire si la
peinture est parlante s'il est là ce
qu'est semaine par les acquéreurs voilà
parler dans cet ordre
alors comme épouse a été comment on dit
que c'est pas dur de votre énorme alors
on ne peut pas maintenant je veux être
c'est quand même de faire tourner
quelques uns et le soir de se retrouver
la maison ensemble ça que je veux dire
mais il voyage beaucoup j'en ai qu avant
ils étaient très tournées du temps ouais
il était tout le temps
aujourd'hui une association comme ça je
pense pas qu'on ait vraiment il
rafraîchit mais marché des enduits
ophuls vivaient dans ses films mais
c'est une erreur mais une erreur
séduisant qu'il n'ait probablement vu ça
de ma famille j'étais trop trop jeune
cinéma commence qu'à 30 ans j'ai détruit
et finalement pensé qu'il fallait mais
parce que j'avais lu jouer non seulement
de notre amour en ce qu'il faut avoir un
grand amour n'en est pas capable les
femmes vous pouvez bien briser ce que
j'avais des bleus
l on souffre certainement et moi tout ce
que je pouvais donner c'est des films
mais les moments un film on sait rien
est ce à cause de ça vous êtes qui fait
finalement c'est parce que vous n'aviez
pas assez à vue donner 30 noms et puis
je regardais aussi moi je copiais donc
je voulais faire je me disais moi après
tout il y avait hors ce noël c'était
wars d'albert marlene dietrich renoir
est 4e ligne parce que j'aime moi aussi
donc c'est un modèle eh bien on voit que
très bon ce modèle permet de faire
certains films épiques les films après
ont du mal à repasser dans dans la vie
et que ça jamais bien bien marché
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aussi heureux après
parce que c'est que ce grand amour
concernés différemment chez themis
maintenant mais je comprends moi je
pense qu'on peut l'être alors beaucoup
plus et que demain et toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les blessés
-
il devient dès le départ
non pas moi je pleure pas chez moi
anna karina ne savait pas non jean luc
godard on était voyou il faut dire la
vérité on prévenu personne on mettait
même des faux noms sont les loges pour
que les gens se rendent pas compte que
l'autre était la cua et godard ça va lui
godard il savait ouais mais elle savait
pas avec eux d'ailleurs on veut un peu
quelque part parce que c'est vrai que
c'était un moment pour enfin pour elle
surtout assez dures luttes qui friment
godard qui dubois moi ça me dérange pas
je suis un vieux du vietnam
c'est là que vous êtes dit j'ai franchi
la limite dont c'est bien peu de
l'impudeur je me suis dit ça
malheureusement bien plus tard vous
l'êtes pas dit sur le coup non jamais
mais après ou bien plus tard j'ai
compris mais voilà il fait je vous dis
je débarque donc là ce soir là ce moment
là vous étiez content de votre cou très
content ce qui j'ai trouvé absolument
extraordinaire c'est qu'elle parle à
l'époque et encore les fils au micro
elle pas rentrer et non de file du micro
ça m'arrivait deux autres fois ça m'est
arrivé avec chainel sinéad o'connor a
wish fais une faute qu'elle avait de
brûler une photo du pape et je lui ai
dit ça et elle a dit ah non vous n'allez
pas me parler de sa gym attendez je vous
parlais pas ce que je veux et elle est
partie toujours avec le fil des
réassureurs cette image de gens qui
partent et puis jimmy somerville aussi
il y met fiche à l'envers et il voit la
première question c'est est qu'est ce
que ça vous fait quand on vous appelle
tronche de patates et il me dit vous
allez vraiment me demander sa vie oui
j'ai partie des chevaux de l'ina nous a
rejoints bonjour à 10 h
alors parlez nous de la place singulière
de bain de minuit et des lunettes noires
dans le paf des années 80 avec il faut
parler à certaines de ses émissions
un dynamiteur ne m thierry ardisson ces
deux émissions qui sont totalement
vraiment totalement inédite
elles sont totalement iconoclaste et
c'est vraiment des ovnis qui arrive dans
le paysage audiovisuel au milieu des
années 80 et pourtant et pourtant
thierry ardisson d'ailleurs vous venez
d'en parler thierry est un enfant de la
td certains d'enfants de la rtf
il était baigné il est complètement
imprégné des émissions les plus
prestigieuses
il est imprégné par l'esthétisme de
dunes désilets de gala ou d'un jean
christophe averty et il est surtout dans
ses interviews le sang il a été bercé
par les interviews très marquante de
denise glaser donc le score
c'est cet enfant de la télé et en même
temps et thierry vous venez d'en parler
aussi c'est un fils de pub et c'est
peut-être ce mélange assez singulier qui
fait que les concepts qu'il va mettre en
place pour la télévision sont totalement
détonnant et d'une certaine façon
révolutionne un peu cette télévision un
peu encore conformiste un des années du
milieu des années 80 et je crois qu'il
faut avant de bain de minuit faut quand
même rappeler la première émission de
télévision de terrain deux socialistes
elle est dingue elle est dingue batteur
chanteur et on comprend pourquoi
et en fait cette émission qui est une
une adaptation add interview pour le
magazine que franck est rock'n folk et
bien c'est ça le concept est simple des
salles des stars interviewé dans son
caleçon commissariat dans des endroits
vraiment toujours très glauque et
brutalisent et brutalisé est alors allé
avec thierry qu'étant en imperméable
mastic et puis alors ambiance quand même
bavure a toujours ans leur stature et
l'adaptation pour la télévision est
tellement détonante et je crois qu'elle
est elle est tellement transgressive et
pardon thierry elle est tellement
déconnante que évidemment la haute
autorité et je pense que c'est une des
rares fois où la haute autorité
intervient et bien demande à tf1 de la
supprimer
au bout du sixième épisode ce que ce que
tf1 ne peut pas refuser
en cause des dérapages enfin l'écart a
pas joué quelques petits dérapages mais
surtout le ton on n'a jamais entendu à
la télévision tu as pris de la coke
on n'a jamais entendu à la télévision
alors se dire combien de fois par
semaine tu es cliqueter clitoridienne ou
vaginale ça ce n'est pas possible même
dans une télévision parce qu'il faut le
rappeler qui est contemporaine quand
même de droit de réponse ou de psy show
c'est pas une télévision compte est
totalement ringard
mais là on va trop loin tous les tabous
tombent et de fait quand même il ya
quelque chose qui se passe il ya un tout
qui est posée nous aurons posé c'est
l'arrivée de l'impertinence et de la et
la provocation à la télévision pas
complètement parce que quand même depuis
joyal en passant par jacques martin
s'empare philippe bouvard ou même
coluche il ya une histoire qui s'écrit
un de l'impertinence et de la
provocation à la télévision ce qui est
nouveau avec thierry ardisson et avec
baffie c'est qu'ils vont
professionnalisme et d'une certaine
façon la provocation et d'impertinence
ils vont la systématiser et puis il en
faut elle s'applique quand même à des
registres bien particulier qui jusqu'à
présent n'avaient pas cours à la
télévision française le sexe la drogue
l'alcool
on en parlait pas en tout cas on n'en
parlait pas avec ce langage très cru ça
rappelle un peu à la limite le ton des
premières radios pirates de certaines
radios pirates mais à la télévision
n'avait jamais parlé de cette drogue de
de cette façon là et donc ce type de
provocation choc choque vraiment
profondément enfin en tout cas c'est
tout à fait nouveau et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on est toujours on
est toujours à la limite du scandale on
est toujours en train de franchir la
ligne et et le téléspectateur il est
emmené par la main et par thierry dans
cette espèce d'expérience transgressive
et surtout c'est ce que je crois que
c'est ce qui fait le succès il est tenu
en haleine c'est à dire qu'on se dit à
quand le clash à quand le clash est
inévitable façon le claj bien tout le
temps et d'une certaine façon moi je
trouve quand on regarde ses émissions
qu'on peut considérer de thierry
ardisson a un peu inventé le buzz
télévisuelle avant même la naissance
d'internet et des réseaux sociaux est en
fait ce qui se met en place
d'une certaine façon avec bones minuit
qui est un peu confidentiel c'est celle
à 5 de berlusconi y aller par façon
façon personne ne la regarde ce que
personne ne la capte très peu de gens la
cape
et s'affirme complètement dans les
missions suivantes et lunettes noires
bon là c'est quand même antenne 2 ça
beaucoup plus d'audience sa race a réuni
quand même parfois plus de 2 millions de
téléspectateurs ce qui est assez
considérable et ça devient un rendez
vous ça devient le rendez-vous drogue
sexe et rock de la télévision de la fin
des années 80 et surtout ça permet une
chose fondamentale enfin en tout cas
pour thierry c'est que ça ça met en
place la marque thierry ardisson le buzz
c'était une envie ou s'éduque ans et
c'était monsieur jourdain faisait du
buzz ça va vous aviez envie qu'il se
passe d'être vraiment parce qu'ils
avaient quand même toute une presse
assez morale qui quand même malgré tout
nous allumer soutien c'est pas aussi là
maintenant on parle calmement mais à
l'époque c'est vrai qu'on faisait quand
même bien allumés et on se faisait et
réprime réprimandé quand même mais pour
en revenir à ce que vous disiez je suis
en remercie c'est tout à fait juste
quand les patrons de l'antenne de mon
reçues il voulait supprimer les enfants
du rock et ils m'ont dit monsieur
ardisson qu'est ce que vous feriez si on
vous donnait le samedi soir et j'ai
répondu je ne ferai pas une émission de
rock
je fais une émission rock à richard
gardet y en a un qui a dit oui nous et
il aurait dit je traiterai tout sur un
plan rock c'est à dire que ce sera
l'état d'esprit rock qui s'appliquera à
tous et pas seulement la musique voilà
et je crois que c'est ce que vous disiez
c'est ça qui est créé une différence de
danse rock n roll on parlait de drogue
ont parlé de sexe on parler de tout ça
j'ai jamais fait que finalement adapté
l'esprit rock et la télévision et ça
c'est fait puisque l'une est à remplacer
les enfants durant l'une est en baisse
dans prog rock c'était à minuit sur
france 2 pas sur antenne 2 à l'époque
est effectivement c'était au début
c'était assez confidentielle et puis bon
voilà alors
les intellos des allumages les journaux
conformiste qui vous allume quand même
et pourtant les politiques viennent
oui ils ont été durs à convaincre non
parce que là c'est pareil c'était avant
les réseaux sociaux c'était à dire que y
venaient et trouvé ça très chic juppé
enfin je veux dire on va aller voir le
premier essai chaban delmas
il était comme true that chick de 200
canadiens chinois bains douches
bon d'un côté comme ça le plus fort
c'est le cas du r lecanu a joke adieu
alors la regarde et on va voir la
première
donc voilà donc c'est vrai que il non ce
n'était pas très dur de l'est quand même
finalement non
certains ont regretté simone veil
étaient pas super contente
honnêtement pas ce que vous avez fait en
plus un reportage sur l'arrestation
valence absents revanche c'était de très
mauvais goût dans la séquence à suivre
alain juppé en auto interview jacques
chaban delmas et madame jean lecanuet et
madame est d'abord parce que on l'a on a
choisi leur passé parce que vraiment la
séquence est intéressante et sa réaction
est intéressante et on voit quelque
chose de très fort
simone veil confronter à ce qui existait
que vous n'aviez pas inventé c'est à
dire les horreurs déversé sur elle par
l'extrême c'est un peu violent
est-ce que devant vous on peut allumer
une cigarette
aubenas mais non ça arrive souvent ça
arrive sur le ca arrive souvent et je ne
suis pas du tout une terroriste en la
matière ce que je crois c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya tout de même une
campagne contre le tabagisme et où les
médecins ont justement demandé on évite
de fumer à la télévision alors c'est pas
moins que ça gêne mais c'est je dirais
dans le cadre de cette action
pédagogique
je crois qu'on peut faire un effort je
vais faire un effort jusqu'à la fin de
set il a vu je ne fais moi pâtit excusez
moi comme tous les gens comme tous les
hommes politiques de la droite libérale
des ondes qui disent nous on fait bien
la différence entre le pen et les
électeurs du ve moi je dis pas je fais
la différence entre les électeurs et
monsieur absolument pas c'est pas du
tout le discours j'ai que je tiens je
vous dis simplement qu'on ne peut pas
savoir je dis je dis d'abord c'est vrai
qu'un certain nombre d électeurs ne le
partage pas tous les
les sentiments et les idées de monsieur
le pen s'était bien qu'il ya une grande
partie de rejet et donc il faut bien
voir les raisons de ce rejet
ce que je dis simplement c'est une
pousse ta si vous voulez matériel qui
fait qu'au moment où les gens votent
on ne sait pas quelle est l'autre sens
ont été pareillement barça devient des
bombes à bas risque puisque si l'on met
les bons libéraux mais c'est pas que ça
vient des bruits c'est que vous n'avez
pas le moyen vous n'avez pas de moyen de
savoir si ces 5% 10%
ça serait âgée un électorat général
parce que c'était si la réponse est non
absolument pas très souvent pour des
attentes et vos premiers
m on a tenté une expérience et a cité la
fête le blanc rouge justement parce que
cette question nous importe c'est à dire
que 20 électeurs de le pen au premier
tour devient un électeur libéral ou
deuxième si on a demandé à notre ami
philippe guérin ici présent une allée
hier la fête du front national a fait le
blanc rouge pour demander aux militants
du front autour de la traîne non ce
qu'il pensait de vous ce qu'il pensait
des gens on va regarder le sujet on va
regarder le sujet je n'aime pas du tout
simone veil simone veil aujourd'hui fait
beaucoup de flat de plein de
sina gré au secours en ce qui concerne
ce que tu es ce qu'a dit monsieur le pen
et simone veil oublie simplement qu'elle
est responsable de la loi sur
l'avortement que ce sont des milliers
d'enfants de bébé que l'on cul dans le
sein de leur mère je trouve ça ignoble
giraud front national n'a pas sa place
ici seulement démocratie simone veil a
droit à la parole comme jean marie le
pen
je n'aime pas du tout madame simone veil
je lui reproche en particulier sa loi
sur l'avortement qui entraînait génocide
de deux centaines de milliers voire de
millions de jeunes français de petits
français et de futurs qui ne se
réaliseront la mère simone veil bon ben
je peux pas trop dire parce que je
connais pas assez mais enfin bon vous me
poserez la question sur n'importe qui je
vous dirai non
c'est toujours pareil il y en a qu'un
c'est le pen
cette surprise pas du tout il va falloir
vous soyez très exigeante avec monsieur
bars ou pas du tout surpris je reçois du
courrier de ce genre fréquemment et donc
ça ne prend absolument si vous montrer
mon courrier il est quelquefois dire que
ça je me sais pas ce que vous dites mais
là je me lasse si vous voulez ce n'est
pas que je
je des douanes cet électorat pas du tout
c'est pas du tout que je trouve que
c'est pas parce qu'il m'attaque mais
c'est simplement sur leur idée quand
leur art
je pense tout de même qu'on a un petit
peu trier là c'est pas vraiment brillé
passer de
c'est le nom dans son micro il y avait
des choses beaucoup plus saignant mais
mais lens info et devant la caméra de
rester
[Applaudissements]
moi je trouve que tu as pas tellement
changé depuis deux ans je t'avais déjà
rencontrés ici sa diète de choc qui
changerait quoi en toi si tu avais une
baguette magique je me donnerai
peut-être la chevelure de robert redford
s'ils voulaient ressembler à qui quand
j'étais petit j'étais petit sans doute à
napoléon
tu crois que tu ferais quoi six de
départ secrétaire général du rpr n'aurez
que l'embarras du choix
j'ai envie de faire plein de choses
écrire par exemple quoi tout et
n'importe quoi tu crois que tu seras
président de la république un jour
toujours rêver si tu étais une star du
rock ça serait qui enfin peut-être un
groupe à moi tout seul
peut-être les rita mitsouko c'est avec
eux que j'ai inauguré la cigale dans les
viiie arrondissement
je souhaiterais site était une star du
cinéma j'avais envie d'être burt
lancaster dans des langues et arts que
tout change pour que tout demeure mal de
villes et de la télé toi cai normale sup
la grecque science pour lennar ne crois
pas que tu as fait un peu trop longtemps
à l'école pour diriger un mouvement qui
veut retrouver ses assises populaires
agents viennent du peuple
puis j'ai bossé on ne les a pas donné
tout ce diplôme puis je suis élu d'un
quartier populaire où je vois des tas de
gens on se compte beaucoup sur le métier
des élus on n'est pas là pour faire des
discours delà pour rencontrer ceux qui
nous font confiance
ça maintient contact quels rapports ou
quelle différence y at il entre le
gaullisme et le chiraquisme à ce
programme de gaulle c'était l'histoire
chirac sélectivité
si de gaulle revenez demain matin ils
penseraient coins de la france 2 88
peut-être qu'il utiliserait deux mêmes
mots qu'il avait utilisé à quelques
années la chienlit
mais je crois qu'il aurait confiance
parce que ya beaucoup de ressources dans
ce pays l'un politique c'est fait pour
imaginer l'avenir tu la vois comment toi
la france de l'an 2000 veut plutôt pas
mal parce que je trouve que
ces jeunes ont du tonus faut une
certaine manière mon admiration
si terry aujourd'hui on reparle de la
bombe atomique du site à du chômage
malgré ça a été le choc alors je crois
qu' aucune raison de se désespérer c'est
quel maître du monde
tu ferais quoi en premier la le
secrétaire-général de rtl avec beaucoup
de choses à dire faire en sorte que les
gens de ce chapeau il pas pour des
questions subalternes reste un grand
rêve ce soir-là aubin il n'y avait pas
robert de niro il était venu le samedi
d'avant ni mick jagger ce sera la
semaine prochaine mais le président de
l'assemblée nationale jacques chaban
delmas
et pas besoin
85 innovons simili c'est impossible il
faut garder le silence
non non j'en sois président a comment
vas-tu qu'elle survient fusent
bienvenue parmi nous merci d'être là
pour la première de balbigny j'ai pensé
que répondre à votre invitation était
une sorte d'obligation à la fois
sentimentale morale artistique
merci quand j'ai su qu'il y avait celui
ci est que j'ai pensé qu' évidemment je
ferai un peuple à côté d'eux mais
qu'après tout comme disait libération de
relance arié libération a dit que
c'était plus fort que madonna jeu suivez
mon regard
vous êtes venu comme mon président je
suis arrivé en avion de bordeaux tout à
l'air vous êtes venu avec le glam non
oui vous avez un avion du glam
oui oui j'ai eu un avion du glam d'heure
sans ça ce n'était pas possible et puis
après on n'est pas venu à pied en bus en
voiture tout bêtement
malgré la prise d'otage avait pu passer
je les ai pas dans ce coup là un bon
accord n'est pas parce que de temps en
temps en boîte
non non pas du tout pas du tout pas du
tout parce que j'ai une vie réglée comme
papier à musique
le matin au petit déjeuner on m'apporte
ma feuille de route et pendant neuf
heures 10h 11h 12h jamais plus de 16
heures mais entre 9 et 16 heures
j'ai un emploi du temps minuté minutes
est minuté minutes et déjoue même faire
un aveu pour aller me laver les mains
disons quand le mur est ce que vers 10
heures dans le militaire eh ben je suis
habillé de gratter sur mes rendez vous
lorsque mon horaire est telle qu'on n'a
pas prévu ça et ma vie est ainsi depuis
40 ans moyennant quoi je me porte bien
jamais pressé j'ai tout mon temps mais
il faut vivre à la minute
alors vous avez quand même des moments
de détente à laurent mais j'ai le
bonheur
michel gilbert
merci d'être venu vous aussi parce que
dans l'émission nous voulons toujours
recevoir les gens comme lorsqu'ils
sortent dans les boîtes ou dans les
restaurants c'est à dire en couple ça
nous fait vraiment besoin jamais mais ça
continue est très bonne et quand vous
sortez cet ensemble toujours justement
une question qui nous brûle les lèvres
si vous êtes toujours très amoureux
chaque fois qu'on vous voit dans des
photos dans paris match en jour de
france vous donnez toujours la main est
ce que c'est pour les photographes ou
est-ce que c'est sérieux ans tu as tu un
actif c'est instagram
c'est un réflexe n'est pas du tout fait
naturel et quoi regarder la non mais
regardez la série
regardez comme elle est faite comme en
volume je ne sois pas amoureux de cette
fille mais là vous allez avoir du mal ce
soir et alors j'essaie alors j'essaie de
j'essaie d'être père choisit souvent
relais et quand j'arrive à être
persuasif alors j'ai un petit retour en
moi ce que je voudrais maintenant je
sais qu'on est dans une boîte
j'aurais quand même que vous pas que
c'est formidable c'est la meilleure de
paris j'ai découvert ça tout à l'heure
mais avec ravissement
c'est la meilleure de paris le voyez que
c'est du très bon très bon ou c'est très
bien organisé et puis julien clerc me
dit que c'était pas du tout drogue
maquereautage et compagnie que c'était
au contraire tout à fait ça vous avez
volé les renseignements généraux vous en
donner de bons renseignements
avez vous savez que les renseignements
généraux ce soir vous fait passer une
fiche entre l'avion la voiture est ici
sur les bains attention il va être là ce
soir sur le présent attention alors j'en
ai vu d'autres
oui on n'a pas hésité à l'eau
représentant 74 vous vouliez devenir
président la république en 86 vous était
prêt à devenir premier ministre
oui alors vous auriez fait mieux que
belgique a rien de mieux que jacques
chirac je n'en sais rien j'aurais fait
différemment
bon j'aurais fait différemment c'est à
dire c'est que j'avais proposé à la
france et aux français un grand dessein
voilà et je crois pas qu'on puisse se
passer d'un grand dessein si on veut
leur enlever le regard des français
relance et l'espérance est réellement
que ce pays se hisse au dessus de lui
même or c'est nécessaire pour ce pays et
j'espère que le prochain président de la
république quel qu'il soit aura
conscience de cette nécessité d'un grand
dessein et qu'il aura lui le dessin par
exemple d'une nouvelle nouvelle société
car tout reste à faire
et je pense que c'est la bonne voie
alors moi je ne suis pas candidat cette
fois ci parce que comme l'avait prévu le
général de gaulle c'est plutôt trop
plaint pas je laisse passer matin je
laisse passer un temps fou à le faire
vous allez faire la campagne de jacques
chirac comme un rat - au premier tour je
le pire est certainement jacques chirac
je suis membre du rpr il est président
du rpm et vous savez dans la vie il faut
toujours jouer
loyal 1 mais quand vous dites on dit
toujours que enfin vous dites que vous
êtes sous-employés un chat bon bien
employer ce serait quoi finalement roman
j'ai toujours pensé qu'en réalité non
meilleur emploi c'était la présidence de
la république
j'aime le canut et bonsoir jean lecanuet
bonsoir voila merci d'être là tous les
deux est-ce que vous sortez beaucoup
dans les boîtes en général c'est une
bonne question et l'arche non parce que
nous avons beaucoup d'occupations entre
paris notre bonne ville de rouen c'est
pour ça que ça me fait d'autant plus
plaisir d'être dans une autre exilé soir
la dernière fois que j'ai chanté dans
une boîte c'est quand on se dirait pas a
dit moi or on est au bar il fait tout
bien
rakia vraiment très très longtemps après
cinq ans et mon mari ne s'est peut-être
pas alors elle avait demandé à certains
de vos proches comment vous deviez vous
habiller alors seriez-vous coquet un
petit peu oui
oh non mais j'ai l'idée est complètement
démodée qui se croit qu'il faut
s'habiller selon les circonstances et
moment de la journée
selon les activités d'ailleurs jacques
ils se moquent souvent de moi parce que
même quand on est tous les deuxièmes
voix changer ou quatre fois par jour de
manière m'a dit tu es
année du temps tu as préparé en avril
mais l'ex comme tous les hommes
politiques on écoute au moins 4 ou sara
lee en même temps l'or sa double de là
dedans bien sûr du temps de la
discussion sur la couleur de la cravate
on va parler sur la première discussion
de notre journée madame lecanu et je
vous présente michael delmarquette un
qui est un mage gens je vous présente
michael delmarquette à un âge très
savants et qui a étudié à partir de
votre lieu de votre heure bien entendu
de votre date de naissance votre thème
astral alors mage est ce que jean le
camus est un avenir politique parce que
c'est la question finalement qui nous
occupe tous ce soir
est ce que dans les astres tu vois pour
lui un avenir politique surtout avec
l'échéance de mai 88 alors justement
mais 88 peut représenter une date
importante dans la mesure où ou jean
lecanuet poisson attendant poisson donc
l'arrivée de jupiter dans le signe du
taureau peut être assez importante dans
sa vie politique est toujours à tu le
vois je pense résidents n'ont
certainement pas président mon premier
ministre à mon avis non ministres
ministres certains ministres s'est déjà
fait vous arrivez manner m'est déjà
arrivé plusieurs plusieurs fois mais il
n'y a pas longtemps en 86 vous avez
failli être bénisse de la défense non
des affaires étrangères tu penses que
tout ça peut recommencer encore je pense
que s'il ya une opportunité à saisir
elle leur a dû emmener en mai en mai et
tu te bases sur quoi pour vous dire saab
sur gm par exemple jupiter de trigone de
jupiter avec le soleil des gens du pays
à ce moment là à ce nom là où cela il
est longtemps
hélas en 1965 lorsque jean-luc animé se
présenter à la présidence de la
république
est-ce que cl tu avais connu tu aurais
pu le prédire l'issue de cette élection
oui certainement on pouvait dire qu'il
n'avait aucune chance d'être élu ah bon
non c'était pas à cause du général de
gaulle c'était à cause des astres à
cause des absolus mans n'était pas connu
à ce moment là un carré de de pluton et
de saturne et de vous laisser aucune
chance en fait mais je pense que c'était
une étape importante pour votre
évolution personnelle le le fait de se
mesurer au pair en fait le fait de
provoquer en quelque sorte le de la
paternité politique et spirituelle de de
gaulle parce que je me trompe pas je ne
me sentais pas pour être élu non je peux
souhaiter tout à fait impossible je me
présentais pour une idée que maintenant
pratiquement tout le monde accepte mais
qui à l'époque était refusé par presque
tout le monde c'est la communauté de
l'europe la construction de l'or alors
maintenant derniers points de cette
astro view vous semblez tous les deux
faire un couple très très unie alors en
termes d'amour mages qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire du coup que le canut et en
termes sentimentaux oui jean lecanuet
est un grand plus de 10 alors est ce
qu'il est vraiment tu dis
il nous dit pas tout j'observe une
censure prudent est-ce qu'il dort égard
du jama par exemple il donne avec un
pyjama à mirka billets de pudeur
il a probablement une grande
extériorisation de sentiments des
chaleurs et sympathique ira et qui
correspond à sa pulsion profonde mais je
crois que bien côté intense presque
religieux quels fondements de son
essence et qui garde pour une nuit que
peux-tu ajouté match sur la vie
sentimentale du couple lecanu et j'ai
l'impression que les travaux domestiques
des travaux ménagers seront très
important dans sa vie qu'elle et son
image comme l'a expliqué la semaine
dernière que pierre juquin c'est un
écueil est un bouquet d'églantine sur un
chemin de montagne alors jean lecanuet
tue-le traduirait comment alors il ya
deux images que j'ai proposé la première
correspond son soleil c'était un homme
nu jusqu'à la ceinture et coupant du
bois ça va c'est un degré de travail
donné les moyens répond quoi oui
compagnie voit même pas si mal ce bar
vous est arrivé de camper au canada le
couple de s'encanailler le mot juste
assez monsieur de pourceaugnac saisi par
la secte actuellement exactement un
grand plus la ville ce mage
c'est un escroc absolue j'avais inventé
un truc qui s'appelait astro view
utiliser les astres pour mieux connaître
les stars dont on reconnaît le
publicitaire tout était vendu quand même
à chaque fois il n'y a pas que des
politiques qu'on a pu voir sous un
nouveau jour dans la séquence suivante
vous allez retrouver juliette binoche
nicola sirkis qui ne fait que que
croître à ce moment là c'est l'homme
d'indochine vincent bolloré tiens tiens
et d'abord jacques martin
réac assumer et à fismes en affirmant sa
détestation de la gauche caviar
quand on s'intéresse un peu à tout on
découvre que tu as un personnage
finalement être plus complexe que tu en
as l'air le dimanche après midi avec une
vision on sait jamais si tu as eu le
certificat d'études seulement aux
baccalauréats ce s'est arrêtée août les
études ça officiellement ça c'est à vous
que j'ai eu le certificat d'études
brevets et puis c'est bien bien bien
bien plus tard j'ai commencé mes études
j'ai recommencé mes études mais est-ce
que ça c'est pas tout ça de la
provocation un peu contre les intellos
et la gauche caviar que tu détestes
maltaises ont rejoint les mythes gast et
si à l'occasion d'un d'un nouveau mai 68
y avait quelque chose j'irai placer
quelques grenades ou à l'observateur
lewis sont les ennemis de caste ça fait
30 ans que ces gens-là chie sur ce que
je fais sur mes livres sur des films sur
les émissions de télé alors pendant une
trentaine d'années j'en ai eu peur on
voit donc
oui je vous remercie de m'avoir dit dans
le journal que dtn [__] ouais voilà
même je leur disais bonjour le soir
quand je les rencontre là chez castel
parce que la gauche va chez castel et
puis un certain bon on évolue tu vois
j'ai attrapé mes 55 ans et pas mal
d'autres choses aussi et je me suis dit
que j'étais complètement con de pactiser
avec mes ennemis donc maintenant tu as
oublié en terre dont il rappelé et il
faut savoir que maintenant je vais tirer
leur ciel est tirée yeux parce que la
gauche que je déteste c'est pas bien
entendu les communisme ou des gens qui
sont vraiment du peuple c'est les faux
sagouin les petits [__] sinon je
suis dans le canard enchaîné disent que
oui on est musulman qui est que oui je
suis un comique pour nocentini
analphabètes que je suis représentant de
commerce comme si dire de quelqu'un qui
était à présent dans le traverse et est
une injure c'est ça ma cisma tu veux
dire représentant de commerce de rodez
but de mu en trousse de tout fait moi
ouais mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
quelque part c'est fini je ne fais plus
de concessions mais il faut qu'il le
sache study pour quelqu'un qui est pas
franc maçon et qui fait pas partie du
racing je me suis pas mal démerder avec
le sata oui oui en revanche qua non j'ai
pas de revanche est plus dans japan toi
dans mon bon je vais maquette n'est pas
ici et quand on a 55 ans
mathématiquement on a moins de temps
moins de temps à passer sur cette terre
on en a déjà puisque la session a fait
le plus gros dont on a fait le plus gros
seins sur ledit 1055 par deux safrans
on n'y arrive pas c'est sûr donc qu'il
reste moins de temps a passé et comme je
suis un sybarites que j'aime le bonheur
que j'aime vivre que j'aime la vie
passionnément je ne vais plus m'emmerder
est beaucoup plus jeune que les autres
je suis arrivé un état raisonnable je
les histoires de la terre ne me concerne
pas tellement parce que le mieux même si
je commets commettait un meurt
aujourd'hui le minimum dont je courais
écopé serait inférieur au temps qui me
reste donc je n'en ai rien à [__]
hier soir en allant chez lui
j'étais plein d'une aimable longueur
printanière et tandis que désire en sa
présence
je pédalais rêveusement sur la salle de
l'airé strates je me senti soudain
caressé par une sieste brise de
printemps
je pensais tout à coup cela aussi c'est
bon
pourquoi ne connais traitons pas une
véritable l'ivresse amoureuse tendre et
profonde au contact du printemps ou de
tous les êtres
on peut aussi se lier d'amitié avec un
hiver avec une ville ou un pays
je me souviens dû être rouge de mon
adolescence
j'avais une liaison toute particulière
avec cet arbre certains soirs prise d'un
désir soudain de le voir je faisais une
demi-heure de bicyclette pour lui rendre
visite et je tournais autour de lui et
peu utilisé par son regard rouge sang
ouais pourquoi devrait-on pas un amour
avec un printemps et la caresse de cet
air printanier était si tendre si
enveloppante que celle de ma main screen
fussent les siennes vous paraissez causé
en comparaison
tel est couvert comment ce bouquin j'ai
découvert je marchais dans les rues puis
c'est un dimanche et j'ai trouvé une
librairie ouverte et
on peut chercher des bouquins comme ça
pour lire pour découvrir quelque chose
les vous et puis je suis tombé dessus
j'ai aimé le titre une vie bouleversée
et puis j'ai senti qu'il y avait quelque
chose dans ce livre le genre je vais
rien vu on n'aime pas
la couverture n'est rien mais je sentais
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui avait
dans ce bouquin qui m'attirait ouais si
nicolas nadau gym pizza ses canards son
rang mayonnaise et son interview vérité
à nicolas salut bonjour
alors on va faire le plein parce que la
borne alors un peu de légende quand même
quoi
oui ça a commencé au second 80 j étais
sauvegarderait ouais j'ai trouvé ça très
bien
[Musique]
bon
donc effectivement et ça remonte à 7 29
septembre quatre mois
et puis j'ai été rigolo trigone après
y'a une aventurière là c'est le groupe
total et wallace et ont découvert la
drogue français s'était fait les fans
c'était un peu façon stone et d'un seul
coup il découvrait la new wave cure
depeche mode revisité si quelques
sympathies absolument pas je sais pas si
c'est ils ont découvert quelque chose
effectivement ça a explosé mais sami
longtemps sa nuit du mois du mois après
ils ont commencé quatre deuxième album
péril jaune
ouais voilà vous étiez pas très content
l'aller les indochine
mais non ce n'était pas très content de
quoi être tranchée en france et que ça
faisait un peu rayé rime avec moi que
c'était pas non c'est pas ça on était
plus ou moins contents d'eux
du mixage de l'album pourtant on a eu
très peu de temps pour nous et qu'il
fallait absolument se précipiter tout
cela quand même non non je sais pas le
mixage était précipité mon ami je sais
qu'on a fait rentrer en 24 heures et ont
mixé au studio en attendant c'était pas
terrible
cette histoire d'enregistrement mais les
titres très bien troisième sexe beaucoup
de succès ouais mais ça me longtemps
c'est vrai ce qui est marrant et 7000
danse pateryn deux fois le vendeur me
dire quand même vendu à peu près 500
mille de moins que possédant ce jeudi
lâchez pas tu dise oui je suis désolé en
famille l'apogée douala est désolé mais
en fait vous savez c'est la maison
disque et de the way en face est sorti
quand même dans tous les pays
non c'est sorti vraiment bien dans 15
pays et ça a marché sur les quinze
présidents
suède canada japon australie
ouais
vous avez plus un succès public critique
ne compte pas
ouais mais quel est le plus important je
sais pas je vous pose la question se
posait la question je vous dirais que
effectivement c'est peut-être que je
veux ton public tout le monde est
critique ouais ouais ça rapporte plus
générale c'est évident ambitieux
c'est vrai que les fans d'indochine
savent pas que c'est un pays croient que
c'est un groupe indochine
ouais je sais que à l'époque 80 puisque
je suis il y avait pierre mauroy et lyne
et webdav
une réunion avec des profs d'histoire et
les élèves qui dit ouais indochine sera
groupe alors ils savaient pas que cet
art est donc remise à l'époque il a fait
un peu la gueule mais bon ceci dit
c'était sais pas c'était pays c'était
une colonie française avec trois quatre
pays s'étaient pas l'impression que
indochine c'est un groupe qui a du
succès épique après j'ai bu après été
obligés d'assurer non je rentre on a été
obligé a effectivement de découvrir
certaines phases 2
ouais on nous a dit et on a dit qu'on
pourrait on n'arrivait pas assimiler le
succès mais bon c'est un truc est
difficilement à cela c'est mieux parce
que c'est pas tout match sonne pour et
puis après on ne sait plus que moi je
suis quoi tout attendri trolls et ouais
j'ai pas eu l'impression pas ce que
c'est
sa bio 1,4 en gros on avait quand même
ramené dans différents groupes
c'est vrai que bon à dos une tout de
suite ça a marché ce qui est
difficilement s'y mettre effectivement
c'est apprendre à être sur scène alors
qu'on a été jeté sans faiblir on s'est
jeté sur scène
exactement ce que vous avez fait des
progrès en sept ans pour moi ouais je
veux dire pour toi peut-être pas mais
moi je sais pas moi je pose est quel
état vous a par exemple c'est qu'on ait
le temps du changement est ce que tu es
ce que tu as l'impression de plus
chanter faux
le circuit n'est pas une foi qui fait
que
pas une fois qu'un parti qu'à
l'intérieur dimensions généreuses sont
pas fous dans le sens que
sont justes
[Musique]
e
bon vous dire qui
attendre que albert et charlene
non mais je sais pas par exemple dans
cette fameuse tipp de libé oui oui non
rihanna du groupe qu'avait dit on fait
de la mayonnaise c'est vrai ou c'est pas
vrai c'est vrai mais on fait de la
mayonnaise nord la mayonnaise mais c est
ce que c'est vrai qu'à un membre du
groupe media on fait de la mayonnaise
aura pour tâche qu'on avait expliqué en
disant qu'effectivement on savait pas
très bien ce qu'on faisait se dire qu'on
faisait on met tait descente et on était
une boîte à rythme était une fois un
batteur toutefois il me tarde que
c'était entre entre du rock'n'roll du
match de la fin ce qui faisait une sorte
de mayonnaise ouaibe attitré ils font du
rock my own est là les gens est en train
de se créer
c'est extraordinaire ce qui t'arrive
parce que d'abord tu réussis très bien
comme je viens de le dire mais surtout
il les gens tu prends une affaire les
papiers à cigarettes ça marche plus le
papier bible ça marche puisque vu
personne n'a l'église le papier carbone
ça marche puisque les photocopieuses
avec 4 francs tu rachètes l'entreprise
familiale
tu fais 3 millions de pertes
2 millions de paires trois ans après tu
fais 100 millions de bénéfices passés
complètement extraordinaire tu est
conseillé de madelin tu rachètes la sq a
qu à sophie calle le cnpf tout ça c'est
un peu l'image
quant au lit dans le journal vincent
bolloré le matin yves à son bureau à 5
heures puis après il va apprendre à 8
heures le petit déjeuner avec ses
enfants et puis il a une compagnie
aérienne mais il a pas de chauffeur
enfin tu es tu vas la messe en fait
comme ça plein de qualité est un héros
moderne quoi mettre cette question je
vais te poser c'est est-ce que tu allais
des défauts ah oui beaucoup
d'abord les bretons sont tous têtu
d'antan pour mijoter une fois qualité
dans les allées on peut en trouver
d'autres il suffit d'aller demander aux
personnes qui travaillent quand il y en
a beaucoup
ouais quand as tu un premier défaut ces
détritus sûrement deuxième défaut
sûrement trop gentil ouais on dirait
c'est pas un défaut de vous l'avez dit
pompidou mais non c'est vrai un peu
gentil s'était je m'occupe de tout ce
que font les gens et puis troisième
défaut je crois un certain nombre de
choses et j'essaie de les appliquer
coûte que coûte même quand l'histoire on
donne un peu tort dans la mythologie
entrepreneuriale tu as un peu remplacé
bernard tapie tu es un peu un tapis
clean quoi et qu'est ce que tu penses de
ta vie je crois que dans la période
le problème c'est essentiellement le
chômage pour chacun chaque chef
d'entreprise qui a créé même en disant
voilà tant mieux pour lui et tant mieux
pour ceux pour qui la crée un emploi
dont je crois qu'il y en a créé je pense
qu'il a fait aussi beaucoup pour le
l'entreprise en général en importance
côté médiatique
donc je crois que son action était très
positive
donc tu penses que le tapis et avec des
fréquences je pense qu'il a fait
beaucoup de chose de très bien et que
c'est très positif pour la france qui
l'a revalorisé il a contribué à
revaloriser pour des entreprises chefs
d'entreprise et que c'est très positif
toi t'as un peu quand même tu es plus
rangée et couettes et l'enfant chéri du
cnpf quand même lui il est pas trop aimé
quand même par les mailles du cnt je
sais pas s'il est pas aimer parler du
cnpm d'abord moi je viens de rentrer au
cnpf ça fait seulement six mois qu'on
m'a demandé d'y rentrer entend bien avec
eux oui je trouve que ça prouve une
grande ouverture d'esprit de prendre
kezman 35 ans comme ça c'est un endroit
où il se passe beaucoup de choses d'un
observatoire économique et social en
fait ça m'intéresse il ya des chefs
d'entreprise qui prennent des cours de
cuisine ou de plaquettes moelle c'est la
grève ça me branche ça m'intéresse alors
il ya un truc moi que j'aime beaucoup
chez toi c'est que tu n'hésites pas à
s'affirmer catholique sociale chose à
fantastic c'est moi je sais pas si je
suis social je suis catholique et je
trouve ça formidable parce que en fait
tu t'entends bien que les syndicats
finalement julien set tu vas pas de
problème tellement avec les syndicats
non on a je crois fait une un certain
nombre de choses ensemble on a on s'est
retrouvé devant une entreprise qui avait
des problèmes et ensemble on a ramé du
même côté et au même moment et ça a été
très positif et on s'est aperçu que
finalement si on était tous ensemble
dans le même bateau et que on
s'entendait bien ça allait mieux que si
on se disputer et donc ça a été très
positif après ça tout à fait je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la crise a fait qu'un
certain nombre de gens sont rendus
compte que le problème maintenant c'est
tellement de se battre entre eux soit un
coeur de l'entreprise
mais plutôt d'essayer de trouver des
clients
contre concurrents à partir du moment où
on a fait cette réalisation tout va
mieux ce que tu crois pas qu'au delà de
la légende quand même c'est vrai qu'à
racheter la sphère familiale avec 4
francs et quand même le fait que quand
il était petit il y avait des gens comme
les pompidou qui venait passer les
vacances ou les fêtes que vous étiez
copains de berne avec edmond de
rothschild est ce que c'est a aidé quand
même pas énormément je suis né
absolument avec beaucoup de chance de
naître dans une famille unie dans une
famille aisée
et puis ensuite dans la reprise des
affaires que nous avons fait avec mon
frère et l'équipe avec qui j'ai
travaillé
nous avons eu la chance de profiter de
la hausse du dollar au moment où c'était
nécessaire
la baisse d'un certain nombre de
matières premières au moment c'était
nécessaire mais la chance exige sais
plus qui disait la chance existe sinon
comment expliquerait tout le succès de
ce qu'on n'aime pas dans notre cas ça a
joué beaucoup
est ce que tu penses que ce qui se passe
en ce moment au niveau boursier c'est
grave
ah oui je crois que c'est enfin c'est
très fâcheux pour ceux qui ont investi
leur argent en bourse tu crois qu'il
peut tu crois qu'il peut y avoir un
crack réel je crois qu'il y aura en tout
cas un grand coup de tabac je pense que
ça correspond à une montée brutale des
taux d'intérêt qui font que la plupart
des gens se disent au fond pourquoi
prendre des risques en plaçant notre
argent et en actions
longtemps les placer dans les valeurs à
revenu fixe je crois qu'aujourd'hui ça
se présente pas très très bien je suis
confiant sur le moyen et long terme
thierry ardisson mais c'était votre
première rencontre avec vincent bolloré
nom s'était rencontré déjà avant c'était
l'époque on était amis et puis n'était
pas aussi riche que maintenant quand il
m'a viré l'année dernière j'ai dit à
quoi ça sert d'être milliardaire si on
ne peut pas se payer tiré ardisson voilà
est-ce que pour moi les milliardaires
doivent être des mécènes mais les
chaînes de télévision en france
appartiennent à des milliardaires qui
n'ont pas d'argent donc à quoi ça sert
aux journaux peuvent me donne pas trahi
bouygues personne ne veut nous met de
l'argent vraiment dans la tête des
jeunes loups des stars américaines des
vedettes populaires et puis moins connu
du grand public des peintres des
sculpteurs des architectes des gens
qu'on ne voyait pas forcément ailleurs
ça aussi c'était votre avis thierry
ardisson moi j'ai toujours dit je le dis
encore et maintenant peut-être c'est un
peu plus audible j'ai toujours dit que
la télévision devait être l'école du
peuple
moi je suis ma grande école mon
université comme on dit philippe claye
c'est l'horaire théâtre j'ai tout appris
j'étais en province un petit gars j'ai
tout appris en regardant le rtf
donc mon idée ça toujours été que la
télévision apporte des choses aux gens
de cesser a pas changé parce que même
d'avoir semé de le dire sur les peintres
mais même dans tout le monde en parle
qui était quand même le grand casino du
samedi soir au sens italien comme disait
d'ormesson
il y avait quand même houellebecq bret
easton ellis tmus d'ormesson
j'ai toujours voulu mêler finalement la
culture avec le divertissement passé
pour moi les émissions culturelles
doivent être divertissante donc les
peintres j'avais envie d'interviewer des
peintres effectivement on avait une
interview sape les interviews pinceaux
et tous les samedis soirs y avait
aujourd'hui quand on y pense quand on
pense à ce qui le service public
11 il y avait des pins vienne a eu son
image inc on va en voir quelques-uns y
avait quand même des grandes stars nam
june paik qui est un maître pour moi il
était là il ya des kits ring mais tous
ces gens là francis bacon construit à
qui j'ai demandé dans un communiqué
signé de tableau par semaine ce que tu
es un peu critique mais bon heureusement
les francis franck maubert qui valorise
et et on peut dire que ce sont ceux là
plutôt qui vous impressionnait way dans
la catégorie de clients que vous aviez
puisque vous dit que les autres vous en
fichier final parce que si vous voulez
moi évidemment j'étais plus impressionné
par francis bacon effectivement par
toutes les starlettes ou par tous les
acteurs de cinéma qu'on recevait je suis
pas trop admirative des gens mais là oui
même si vous les entendiez parfois loin
de leur art dans l'interview volume en
leur demandant combien il peignait de
tableau aussi il faisait la vaisselle
oui parce que je j'ai toujours une chose
qui m'a toujours déplu à la télévision
c'est l'animateur qui veut montrer à
l'invité qu'il est aussi intelligent que
lui c'est le syndrome guillaume durand
moi si vous voulez que vous avez produit
que j'ai produit est dans sa france
derrière nantes que je veux dire c'est
que moi j'ai toujours été un peu le sens
faire le béotien non plus mais j'étudie
chaude mais vraiment au niveau du
téléspectateur je pose des questions
curieuse que j'aimerais voir poser je me
mets pas au même niveau jamais vraiment
je demande des questions voici donc deux
grands noms de l'art contemporain
francis bacon et keith haring et juste
après un formidable numéro au piano du
un grand compositeur lalo schifrin 1
bonsoir francis bacon merci d'être venu
ici au bas je crois que vous connaissiez
si cette boîte de nuit avant
malheureusement pas non à aller à terme
en intéressant maintenant je voudrais
vous dire vous allez me tutoyez c'est ça
pierre vous allez au palace à l'époque
de new fabris
oui je suis allé deux trois fois parce
que j'ai connu par brice un peu et
voilà mais s'est dit tellement de choses
qu'elles fassent tout ce que tu peux
arriver à lui mais sa vie est tellement
dur n'est ce pas je travaille toute la
nuit dans l'es2 vous avez tant les deux
boîtes
mais oui c'est un homme de la nuit mais
vous aussi vous êtes un homme de la nuit
vous travaillez là même la nuit
vous travaillez la nuit où vous allez
dans les jeux d'habitude je suis dans
les bars et parce que je trouvais très
bon le matin je me lève de contribuer à
la lumière et je commence à ces moments
de ce travail j'ai jusqu'à minuit à midi
ou à une
et puis je dresse la journée pour moi
pour boire et pour passer l'année avec
les autres et vous avez bien boire
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte livresque
engendre non je savais je peux c'était
en russie en italie pour alors qu'est ce
que vous voulez il veut il vaut mieux
vivre pour oublier la réalité ou
quoi pas
parce qu'en fait dans vos tableaux dans
votre peinture vous raconter c'est un
peu la solitude la mort la difficulté
d'être le
quel est le préféré la réalité ou le ou
la cruauté de votre peinture parce que
c'est un monde en fait
traduction
mais la vie est qu elle est si vaste
plus cruel que vous peinture beaucoup
plus cohérent et on on sait vraiment
quand on part de ce côté de ma peinture
il faut penser à la vie et on passe la
vie bras dessus bras dessous avec
l'homme avec la mort la mort nous
accompagne toujours
[Musique]
et dans vos dents au tableau vous pour
vous peignez essentiellement des
portraits
quels sont les très souvent les gens
sont beaux et quand une fois paient-ils
ce qu'ils deviennent les clés de votre
notion de la laideur et de la beauté
cela s'est par la même chose bien sûr
mais d'habitude je fais la portée des
gens que je connais bien parce que les
gens j'aime voit les fêtes les gens
beaux mais tant en travaillons on est
on les fait souvent l'est parce que ça
marche pas mieux dans
dans le sens de la vie les deux sens de
l'esthétique ça m'a souvent mieux parce
qu'il faut des formes et la vie pour le
vous donner pour vous pour attraper la
réalité déformée la vie pour mieux la
retrouver
oui vous êtes aujourd'hui sans doute que
le plus grand peintre vivant
je peux confirmer cette question vous
savez ça passe tellement vite il est
allé moment voilà en deux jours en
trouver un autre
quand quentin grp aigner il pleurait
très souvent avant d'attaquer un tableau
surtout quand c'est un portrait alors
vous vous baignez sensuellement des
portraits est-ce que vous avez ce
sentiment de danger de mort
quand vous peignez sait pas quand ça
sera toujours temps et toujours
on s'est toujours occupé à la mort quand
on est très jeune on pense pas cette
chose là mais avec l'âge savez ça
forcément ça c'est puis on dit en guise
en collant boisson vous avez commencé à
peindre fait assez tard vers l'âge de 30
ans oui c'est ça qu'est ce que vous
faisiez avant d'en avant a joué contre
nous et il va faire chaud
bah oui j'étais tanné de change tout
quand j'avais un peu le cas vient quand
j'avais un peu la gent
je m'en disent justement on n'avait pas
omis rien faire vous aimiez le jeu je
crois non j'adore le jeu parce que de
temps en temps ça m'a beaucoup aidé mais
vous savez à la fin j'ai perdu j'ai
perdu beaucoup mais elle sera convoquée
non je jouais la volée
le jeu le plus belge mon rôle est ce
parce que c'est seulement là où je vais
souvent gagné vous avez un numéro ou
plusieurs numéros favoris parle pas tout
à fait non ça change aujourd'hui de
jouer encore oui je pense que vous savez
maintenant à londres un peu joué
il y attend de casino bas partout ça
vous convient à une toile de francis
bacon
comment une toile vous vous combien à
peu près à 100 je sais pas parce que
c'est ce que la carie me donne et 6 kg à
quel prix et les vents moi je sais pas
non est ce que vous vous souhaitez que
vos oeuvres soit dans un musée bacon
après un prêt vous asseoir une fondation
noms font pire sinon je n'aime pas
toutes ses sondes merci encore qu'on a
fait maintenant on peu partout ça vous
gêne pas que ce soient éparpillés
comment que ça vous gêne pas qu'il y en
ait un peu partout dans tous les pays du
monde c'est un collectionneur n'ai pas
envie de voir ça quelque part dans vous
amuser des cas nous c'est quoi la vie
d'un tableau une fois que vous l'avez
fini l'idéal pour vous c'est quoi que
ses pneus le tas de sa part ça chez moi
et voilà j'en vois tout de suite à la
galerie et réussi le bon ils vont pas
souvent pose mes tableaux sont toujours
très difficiles à vente
quel est votre votre production obtenue
combien de tableau par semaine par
semaine
oui non je ne vais pas vous savez par
semaine par mois c'est pas moi parents
ou ses parts avec cette c2 autoire cette
quantité qu être deux seulement
hélas les vingt toiles sont exposées à
la galerie lelong rues de téhéran à
paris son seul travail le fruit de
combien de deux ans
oui mais ce qui est curieux notre
peinture c'est que depuis le début
depuis les premières qu'aussi fiction
1943 quelque chose comme ça je n'ai pas
ce cas aujourd'hui
c'est toujours le même travail la même
obsession on retrouve notamment
l'obsession du sens là qui est
concrétisé par une toile ou seulement
une tâche de sang nous te laver quand
j'ai fait la crucifixion 7 et part parce
que je ne suis pas du tout religieux
mais il est on avait des crises fiction
qui m'a beaucoup touché comme les pôles
par télé
c'est un autre de tuer mabhouh et et les
gens comme ça mais c'était alors à cette
époque là quand j'ai commencé je n'avais
pas vraiment un sujet alors sept à cause
de ses tableaux que j'aime énormément
les gaules waltz et jim a prouvé que
j'ai commencé avec les crucifixions mais
c'est pas parce que je suis religieux
que je vais les deux sélections s'est
éteint c'est un sujet et qu'est ce qui a
déclenché en fait votre votre goût pour
la peinture votre attirance pour la
peinture quand vous êtes dit je vais
devenir peintre
c'est une exposition picasso à paris
j'ai vu oui j'ai vu à une exclusion par
picasso s'est hissée rosenberg à cette
époque là encore c'est même par les
picasso que je préfère mais en même
temps j'ai pensé à pourquoi je peux pas
essayer vers la peinture jg c'est
ambitieux ambitieux oui
[Musique]
cissé ring bonsoir you are known as le
michelangelo devenu obsolète
yet you don't want to be gold race et
histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
william burroughs ignorait ce jeune
couple à la ville
nessma
[Musique]
nîmes et bastia 3 roland bailleul
exact
[Musique]
je connais tu as échoué à notre qui
parient watts painter ou double
en effet un magasin de mr aulas le
chiffre in tue beaucoup moins connue que
ta musique finalement et cette musique
géniale qui a fait le tour du monde sur
laquelle on danse encore aujourd'hui à
paris dans un endroit dont je ne citerai
pas le nom tous les mardis soirs truc tu
joues trois extraits de thé composition
et puis ensuite les gens comprendront
qui tu es
[Musique]
e
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est mme alix lalo schifrin en avant
il y en a un autre qui est pas mal aussi
c'est mission impossible les enfants un
petit bout
[Musique]
m
merci lancé die parce que en sept ans
cette boîte a ouvert il ya dix ans c'est
là dessus pour danser avec philippe
routier ou amis ont dansé sur mission
impossible il ya un troisième que je
voudrais que tu l'aies gentillesse de
jouer parce que alors là c'est le tube
total en france c'est les babines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
donc
à
oh
merci alors merci beaucoup je suis très
heureux parce que j'ai fait vraiment
partie des gens que j'idolâtre un peu et
je n'aurais jamais pensé que je te
rencontrerait je connais c'est en ont
chahuté et fait ça mais j'aurais jamais
pensé avoir la chance de rencontrer un
jour je suis très très heureux que tu
sois là j'ai aussi très content d'être
ici c'est très à l'aise c'est ça que
c'est vraiment tout va bien je suis
admiratif la cipa leur dise on connaît
d'habitude
angélique c'est le fan voilà il ya lui
il ya quand j'ai rencontré à rio pour
une émission qui s'appelait long
courrier j'ai rencontré tom jobim
ouais alabama donnait comme ça je me dis
quelle chance j'ai eu dans ma vie de
pouvoir rencontrer des gens comme lalo
schifrin tom jodie meeks tiens c'est à
dire la lâcher l'affairé paraît souvent
et donc des regrets des gens des stars à
qui vous auriez aimé pouvoir dire votre
admiration et puis ça s'est pas fait
parce que jeune lennon il est mort avant
que je fasse de la télé mais j'aurais
c'est vraiment quelqu'un pour qui j'ai
énormément des 1000 aces sur des
contemporains c'est le seul non non
franchement j'ai pas on dit tout le
temps qui t'aurait mais interviewé gérer
vous savez je veux dire la vérité
j'avais une approche qui était un peu
comme un dentiste
il s'assoit sur le fauteuil je les opr
et il s'en vend et je passe au suivant
parce que si j'avais réalisé ce que
j'étais en train de faire
j'aurais moins bien fait c'est ce qui
m'a sauvé finalement c'est pas me rendre
compte de ce qui m'arrive est
franchement pas ce qui jette un terme
est tellement de gens que j'avais
gorbatchev je vais faire ça alors que
tout le monde en rêve et gorbatchev à 2
2 1 2 2 comme ça donc ce que je peux
dire c'est que j'avais à ce que j'étais
en train de faire
j'aurais pas fait et al'inverse des gens
pour qu'ils vous aviez quand même de
l'affection une admiration particulière
et qui sont sortis déçus ou fâchés de
l'émission n'ont aps le mans je dis
simplement des gens avec qui je suis ami
ils sont jamais contents parce que quand
quant à yvan attal bien sur mon plateau
et que je le fais chier avec sur le
gainsbourg ils me regardent ils
s'étaient je sais que ça m'emmerde et il
s'est blessé
donc quand ils sont là il est moins
content bon jeu
boulot hein je peux pas pas de
passe-droit rebonds en tout cas c'est sa
forme un très bel ensemble et de très
belles archives pour le patrimoine
télévisuel et vous travaillez en ce
moment avec avec li da pour la mise en
valeur de ses émissions je suis très in
a c'est à dire nous on est très fier de
ça tombe bien
am a consacré un site il ya quelques
années
ainsi tu tout mais mes émissions étaient
répertoriés ensuite ils ont fait un
coffret qui s'appelle la boîte noire de
l'homme en noir
là on fait donc la première chaîne pour
un animateur je compte c'est la première
fois qu'ils s'appellent il n'a ordi tube
qui va et on vous allez dans quelques
jours dans quelques jours on va pouvoir
retrouver des morceaux choisis par
thierry et par l'ina de toutes les
émissions de thierry présenté par thiery
qui rex plique pourquoi cette émission
commenté décrypte un petit peu et et
très franchement on a visionné tout
l'été qui cimente et toutes ces
émissions on ne s'ennuie pas d'accord
mais dans la redite tube arty suivre sur
youtube par dina non non non répond à
poser on aime bien les gens ce qu'ils
finissent par ina mais là quand on
produit avec l'ina deux documentaires
sur le rtf justement qui s'appelle ou
rtf ils ont inventé la télévision avec
philippe thuillier et lina comme
coproducteur et j'ai à coeur
effectivement maintenant je suis quand
même dommage respectable expérience quoi
voilà j'ai à coeur de transmettre
voilà tout simplement que les jeunes
générations voit ce qu'on a fait que le
rta tafer très belle voix off et chic
que la boire merci
d'être venu revisiter ces quelques
moments de lunettes noires pour nuits
blanches et de bain de minuit merci à
vous thierry ardisson et merci à des
chocs et à très bientôt pour de
nouvelles aventures dans les archives de
l'ina
[Musique]
à
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
levine a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez
un pouce bleus